bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
ce matin alors le coc vite 19 ans sera
au coeur des échanges que peut-on
attendre de ce sommet virtuel une
stratégie multilatérale pour sortir de
la crise sanitaire le je pense que ce gd
sera un g20 pour rien malheureusement
j'ai raisons la première c'est que comme
vous l'avez dit il est soudain format
virtuel donc les chefs d'état se
rendront au sort en direct donc nous y
aura seulement qu'il n'y aura pas ce
contact humain et les discussions en
coulisses et les apartés fructueux les
que les grandes réunions de ce sommet
ensuite tout le doubs les chefs d'état
arrivent à un autre en ordre dispersé
englué dans une crise sanitaire et
surtout la crise l économie qui tient de
découle donc la croissance mondiale
rétine et la seule lueur lueur d'espoir
en fait actuellement ses habitants place
la mise à disposition du vaccin pour le
marché alors l'allègement voire
l'annulation de la dette des pays
pauvres est également au menu de ce
sommet est-ce que vous pensez que voilà
on peut pas revenir tout de même à des
accords concernant cet allègement de
dette
mais je pense pas peuvent pas rapidement
puisqu'on attend d'être l'autre problème
possible ce g20 c'est que tout le monde
dépendent du à la résultats finaux et
officiels de l'élection
donc tant que alors j'ai vu que donald
trump participants au sommet mais tous
les autres chefs d'état attendus
vraiment la transition cette transition
chaotique est un conte s'est déroulée au
stade mi temps que unia hors d'âge
officiellement un nouveau président
américain entend alors le secrétaire
général de l'onu antonio guterres esch
qui demandent justement l'aide des pays
du g20 dans cette course ont au vaccin
pour les mettre à disposition le plus
vite possible et ce que vous pensez
qu'ils vont être généreux
ces pays du g20 c'est ça le problème
chacun voit midi à sa porte
donc pour l'instant il ya quand même une
réaction à cet égoïste où tous les pays
donc encore une fois ils vont essayer de
temporiser mais dans l'intérêt de
relancer la relancer la croissance
mondiale alors on parle de chiffres
assez important et encore une fois c'est
un suspens il faut d'abord arriver à
roland qui se multiplient et c'est pas
évident et encore une fois tant qu'il
n'y aura pas le président américain a
officiellement élu on va dire les
décisions seront quand même nos mises de
côté devra attendre un nouvel le nouveau
locataire alors c'est la première fois
que l'arabie saoudite qui est le seul
pays arabe
d'ailleurs à faire partie du g20 présidé
organise ce sommet qu'elle est longée
pour le royaume wahhabite tout
simplement redorer son blason
depuis la sphère khashoggi ahmed bin
salman le prince héritier d'arabie
saoudite
a subi une campagne mondiale de
reproches de critiques suite donc à
l'assassinât journalistes saoudiens
opposants au régime et cruellement
assassinés saoudite à istanbul donc
c'était un moyen pour l'arabie saoudite
de redorer son blason mais voilà comme
quoi le fait que ce sommet soit à 100%
virtuel avoir moins d'impact sur sur
l'image de l'arabie saoudite qui a
encore une fois beaucoup beaucoup
critiqués on a vu pas mal de orange et
ont appelé les pays à condamner à
condamner le royaume pour ses atteintes
aux droits de l'homme
donc malheureusement pour l'arabie
saoudite c'est quand même un mono au
mauvais moment pour redorer son blason
dans l'es6 merci beaucoup
lombardi d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes géologue et
spécialiste du moyen-orient